today is the deadline to finish the
counting of ballots here in clark county
officials expect to finish tonight
hector mejia live at the election
headquarters in north las vegas with the
latest up there hector good morning
good morning john and this is where
we've been getting daily updates from
the registrar voters joe gloria who
yesterday told us
this has been a really stressful
election and he said
he's proud of his staff despite the
sharp criticism that's been thrown at
them over the last week
and today election workers will finish
counting the last remaining ballots in
clark county
all that's left are the ones that needed
a signature verification
the election department here in north
las vegas says it expects finishing that
process by tonight
yesterday registrar voters joe gloria
reported that
549 ballots that needed signature or an
id verification were done and processed
also all mail and votes had been
tabulated as of yesterday so they're
almost done
clark county says it is on schedule to
finish everything on time
gloria is confident they can make it
happen by tonight
we've been on track with everything as i
started from the beginning saying we
will finish on time
so yes we'll be ready to do whatever
comes our way
we have seen some really close neck and
neck local races
if a recount is requested the county has
five days to get that started and five
days to get it all done
we're told ballots would be counted
recounted
the same way and today we'll learn more
information about when we might learn
more
about the provisional ballots the county
and the state were sorting through
thousands of provisional ballots trying
to determine which ones
were eligible reporting live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now